mes chers collègues madame la Présidente
nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir ce
matin lors de la Rodière qui assure la
présidence de l'Autorité de régulation
des communications électroniques des
postes de la distribution de la presse
de 2 ans presque jour pour jour mesdames
la Présidente nous avions eu l'occasion
de vous entendre en mars 2021 peu après
le début de votre mandat nous aviez
alors fait part de l'avancée des
programmes de déploiement des réseaux
numériques s'agissant du plan France
très haut débit et du New Deal mobile
bien entendu l'aménagement numérique a
connu beaucoup d'actualités en 2 ans
avec l'accélération du déploiement des
réseaux la publication récente du plan
de fermeture du réseau cuivre d'orange
dans un premier temps je souhaiterais
faire un point d'étape sur la couverture
en fibres optique du territoire
pouvez-vous nous indiquer où on est le
déploiement de cette technologie au
regard de l'objectif de généralisation
de la fibre prévue pour 2025 en
distinguant entre la zone très dense la
zone d'appel à manifestation d'attention
d'investissement
ditesone amis et des zones
s'agissant de la zone amie notre
commission alerte depuis plusieurs
années sur les retards pris par Orange
et SFR dans les déploiements l'opérateur
historique s'était engagé à rendre
raccordable d'ici fin 2020 100% des
locaux des communes sur lesquelles il
s'était engagés or comme la déplorer cet
automne notre rapporteur pour avis sur
les crédits relatifs à l'aménagement du
mairie du territoire Jean-Michel
Houlgate non seulement cet objectif
n'était atteint qu'à 87% en fin d'année
2022 mais on constate un ralentissement
préoccupant des déploiements dans cette
comment la société Orange
justifie-t-elle cette situation et où en
est la procédure de mise en demeure
lancée à son égard par l'ARCEP
face à la persistante de ces retards ne
faudrait-il pas envisager de passer à
l'étape des sanctions
la réaction d'orange ne s'étend tout à
fait attendre puisque selon nos
informations l'opérateur aurait saisi
début février le Conseil d'État afin de
soulever une question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité à l'encontre du
pouvoir de sanctions de l'ARCEP comme il
l'avait déjà fait en 2019 afin de se
rétracter
faut-il y voir une volonté de
déstabiliser le régulateur voir une
remise en cause des objectifs assignés
par le Parlement et le gouvernement
attirent d'aménagement numérique du
territoire je souhaite également aborder
la fermeture du réseau cuivre orange
sujet indispensable du déploiement de la
fibre et qui va sans doute gagner en
ampleur dans les années prochaines je
rappelle que depuis 2020 des
expérimentations sont conduites par
Orange dans plusieurs communes en vue de
la fermeture du réseau cuivre quelles
enseignements tirez-vous de ces
expériences notamment s'agissant du rôle
de facilitateur que peuvent jouer l'État
et les élus locaux dans la conduite de
cette ambitieux projet
en décembre dernier le premier lot de
162 communes dans lesquelles le
processus de fermeture va être engagé
dès 2023 a été rendu public or la
complétude du réseau fibre n'est pas
assurée dans l'intégralité de ces
communes alors qu'il s'agit d'un
préalable à la fermeture du réseau
cuivre serons-nous en mesure de
respecter les calendriers de fermeture
envisagée enfin en attendant
l'extinction totale du cuivre prévu à
l'horizon 2030 l'entretien de cette
infrastructure va demeurer un point
d'attention majeur pour les territoires
si le déploiement de la fibre avance
bien à l'échelle nationale de fortes
disparités territoriales demeure selon
le rapport de France stratégique de
janvier 2023 sur le plan France très
haut des débits certains départements à
dominante rural notamment l'Ardèche la
Dordogne ou encore la Nièvre dépendent
toujours à plus de 25% du réseau cuivre
des problèmes de qualité de service ont
régulièrement été déplorés sur ce réseau
ces dernières années où en sommes-nous
aujourd'hui
avons-nous la garantie orange
maintiendra ses investissements dans
notre tien du réseau un niveau suffisant
et ce malgré la décroissance tendancelle
du nombre d'abonnés ADSL il est capital
que leur Seb joue pleinement son rôle de
vigie sur ce sujet avant de laisser mes
collègues vous interroge à leur tour je
vous cède la parole madame la Présidente
pour répondre à ces quelques points
soulevés je vous remercie
merci merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
merci de votre accueil au Sénat ce matin
pour évoquer des enjeux que nous
partageons tous et que vous évoquez dans
vos questions ces enjeux qui touchent le
quotidien des Français celui d'avoir un
accès à Internet à très haut débit de
qualité chez soi ou en déplacement ou
encore de disposer d'un service postal
fiable ou en fin de trouver son journal
préféré chez son marchand de journaux je
suis venue accompagnée de deux membres
du collège de l'ARCEP ce matin qui sont
en tribune
je voudrais les citer Serge habiteboul
et Joël cotoni et vous connaissez aussi
ma directrice générale Cécile Dubarry je
suis venue aussi accompagnée de ma
conseillère Virginie Mathot monsieur le
Président merci de vos questions je vais
bien sûr y répondre mais j'aimerais si
vous me le permettez évoquez la
situation des deux autres secteurs
réguliers par l'AR rapidement afin de ne
pas les oublier aussi on parle beaucoup
des télécommunications mais je pense que
les services postaux et la distribution
de la presse sont aussi des services qui
touchent le quotidien des Français
dans le domaine de la distribution de la
presse-papier dont la régulation a été
confiée à la recette fin 2019 juste
avant la faillite de préalis nous avons
un contexte très difficile
d'abord par un changement des usages la
vente des 7 principaux journaux
quotidiens par les marchands de presse à
chuté 37% entre 2019 et 2022 mais aussi
du fait du contexte économique actuel
avec la hausse du prix du papier
la hausse des carburants et l'inflation
qui pèse lourdement sur ce secteur comme
sur d'autres aussi mais avec la
spécificité de la hausse du prix du
papier nous avons encore de nombreux
chantiers dans le secteur de la presse
par exemple la mise en oeuvre effective
de la corde assortiment qui donne plus
de liberté au marchands de presse ou le
chantier de la rémunération des
marchands de presse que nous allons
ouvrir cette année
c'est majeur pour l'attractivité de ce
métier ou encore la mise en place de la
comptabilité réglementaire
nous aurons attentifs à accompagner le
secteur en pleine mutation pour autant
nous sommes conscients la frigidité de
la filière et il faut vraiment que les
acteurs réfléchissent à une amélioration
et une optimisation de leur organisation
permettant de garantir la pérennité de
la distribution de la presse
un mot aussi sur la Poste qui comme vous
le savez fait face à une réduction de
son activité historique de distribution
du courrier la baisse de cette activité
a en effet coûté 600 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires à la poste en 2021
les prévisions sont les mêmes pour 2022
dans ce contexte l'équilibre économique
du service universel postale est remis
en cause le Parlement nous a d'ailleurs
confié une nouvelle mission dans la loi
de finances pour 2022 celle d'évaluer le
coût net du service universel postal
avec un coût estimé par l'arsèpe à 1,6
milliards d'euros et inversement de
l'État à la est égal à 520 millions
d'euros au titre de l'année 2020 21 nous
adorons donc pu constater l'absence de
surcompensation nous avons aussi rendu
cette année des avis sur la nouvelle
gamme des services inclus dans le
service universel lancé par la poste en
janvier 2023
concernant les enjeux de la régulation
du secteur des télécommunications je
propose de commencer rapidement par le
mobile et plus précisément un point sur
le New Deal ce changement de paradigme
dans l'attribution des fréquences sous
l'impulsion politique des élus a été
l'engagement de tous gouvernement et
arceps pour la conception
opérateur bien sûr pour le travail
collectif et constructif réalisé
collectivités dans le choix des zones à
couvrir et harcèdent pour le contrôle
des obligations ça fonctionne bien la
première obligation que vous connaissez
tous est le dispositif de couverture
ciblée sur les 5000 sites à déployer par
opérateur
1786 choisi par les collectivités et
c'est bien cela la nouveauté c'est
l'association des collectivités dans le
choix des zones à couvrir donc 1786 ont
été mis en service
au 30 septembre 2022
dont la très grande majorité plus de 90%
sont quadris opérateur
mais le New Deal c'est aussi la montée
en débit sur certaines zones où la fibre
n'est pas encore déployée avec 1000
sites de 4 gifix non plus de 1/3 ont été
mis en service à date c'est aussi la
génération la généralisation de la
technologie 4G sur tous les sites
mobiles des opérateurs ou encore
l'obligation de fournir
une solution d'appel sur Wi-Fi
permettant c'est une fonctionnalité très
utile pour améliorer la couverture à
l'intérieur des bâtiments disposant du
wifi c'est également l'obligation de
couverture des axes routiers
prioritaires ou encore l'exigence de
qualité de sa vie dans les obligations
générales des opérateurs ces deux
dernières obligations vont aussi
conduire à l'implantation de nombreux
nouveaux sites
concernant la 5G après les inquiétudes
citoyennes et politiques apparues en
2020 et 2021 les travaux de concertation
et de débats organisés par les
collectivités dans lequel nous avons été
régulièrement associés ont permis
d'apaiser la situation et les opérateurs
sont aujourd'hui en phase avec leurs
obligations de déploiement
parallèlement sur les réseaux fixe la
fibre monsieur le Président est devenu
le réseau d'accès internet de référence
pour les Français puisqu'en 2022 la
barre des 50% des abonnements à Internet
au débit et très haut débit a été
franchi et le nombre de locaux rendus
raccordaba la fibre approche aujourd'hui
les 80%. et pour répondre plus
précisément à votre question concernant
chacune des zones
et voilà je l'ai là donc le taux de
déploiement de la fibre en zone très
dense et 90% des locaux le taux en zone
ami est égal à 88% en zone rip c'est aux
alentours de 62% de locaux couverts
avec
environ en 2022 4 millions de nouveaux
locaux rendus raccordables nouvellement
raccordable
le plan France au débit est un succès
collectif c'est d'ailleurs ce que
souligne France stratégie dans son
récent rapport d'évaluation mettant en
avant plusieurs facteurs clés de succès
le premier la stabilité dans le temps du
cadre réglementaire mis en place dès
2009 qui a apporté une prévisibilité
essentielle aux investissements des
acteurs privés comme des acteurs publics
c'est le fruit d'un choix de régulation
résolument tourné vers l'investissement
pour permettre l'aménagement numérique
des territoires portés par les acteurs
privés et les politiques publiques le
deuxième facteur clé de succès qui a été
mis en place c'est la gouvernance du
plan qui est associé tout le monde
gouvernement Arcep parlementaire
collectivités opérateurs un peu comme
dans le cas du New Deal même si le
contexte est différent l'implication de
tous dans un objectif commun celui
d'apporter une connectivité fixe à très
haut débit à chaque Français à chaque
entreprise permet d'obtenir des
résultats
ce succès du plan France très au débit
ce sont des efforts industriels et
humains tout à fait remarquables de la
part des opérateurs et des collectivités
je veux le saluer ainsi que l'ensemble
des hommes et des femmes qui chaque jour
œuvrent sur le terrain au déploiement
des réseaux
dans ce contexte quels sont nos
priorités pour les années à venir
la qualité de service sur la fibre a été
sans doute ma première priorité lorsque
j'ai été nommée il y a deux ans comme
présidente tout le monde se félicitait
du volume des déploiements qui a tenu à
des niveaux records avec à l'époque près
de 6 millions de nouveaux locaux rendus
raccordables fin 2020
mais il n'y avait pas une semaine sans
que je ne reçois un courrier d'un élu me
faisant part des situations
invraisemblables et inacceptables vécue
par nos concitoyens témoignages que vous
recevez tous aussi en tant que
parlementaire cette situation m'a
conduit à prioriser les travaux sur ce
sujet en 2021 les opérateurs n'avaient
toujours pas mis en place les processus
de contrôle ni les outils permettant de
tracer les interventions effectuées sur
les réseaux et d'identifier les
responsables des malfaçons et des
dégradations sur les réseaux c'était ni
vu ni connu pas vu pas pris pour celui
qui débranchait un client pour
rebrancher le sien les opérateurs
étaient aussi dans un certain déni de
l'importance du sujet à son habitude la
recette a objectiver la situation en
analysant les indicateurs collectés
depuis avril 2021 et on a tiré plusieurs
enseignements
d'abord certains réseaux environ 2% du
parc des lignes fibres concentrent les
incidents beaucoup plus qu'ailleurs cela
concerne principalement deux opérateurs
d'infrastructures
altitude pour les réseaux exutor
ex-covages dans l'Essonne et dans le
Calvados et XP fibre pour certains
réseaux en Île-de-France et dans le
Rhône à l'automne 2022
ces deux opérateurs nous ont présenté
des plans de replays complètes des
réseaux concernés lacep effectue le
suivi de ces plans de reprise afin de
veiller au respect par les opérateurs
des engagements pris les premiers
travaux réalisés montrent quelques
améliorations
ensuite à la demande de l'ARCEP et du
gouvernement la filière a remis un plan
d'action en septembre dernier pour
améliorer la qualité des réseaux fibres
ce plan inclut la mise en place d'outils
et des processus permettant un réel
contrôle des interventions sur le
terrain l'engagement d'avoir des
techniciens qualifiés et formés pour
assurer le travail correctement que ça
soit chez le client ou sur les réseaux
et aussi la remise en état des
infrastructures dégradées au fil de
l'eau la mise en oeuvre de ce plan par
la filière est en cours l'art CEP en
assurin suivi et nous serons
particulièrement vigilants sur son
exécution
c'est un jeu de qualité de service nous
paraît fondamental parce qu'il n'est pas
acceptable que la promesse technologique
et les investissements massifs réalisés
soient ternis par des pratiques non
professionnelles ou sur certains ou à
cause de certains réseaux qui ne donnent
pas satisfaction
mais c'est en jeu est aussi important
dans la perspective de la fermeture du
réseau cuivre par Orange projet
structurant pour l'ensemble de la
filière et pour les Français en effet
pour permettre et réussir la fermeture
du réseau cuivre il faut d'abord pouvoir
compter sur un réseau fibre bien
construit et bien exploitée pour vouloir
fermer le cuivre il faut aussi que les
déploiements des réseaux en fibres
optique soit terminé
or autant les déploiements aux zones
d'initiatives publiques ont un rythme
soutenu aujourd'hui cela représente
environ les trois quarts des
déploiements fibres aujourd'hui autant
nous constatons un ralentissement
inquiétant des déploiements dans les
autres trades mais aussi dans les zones
moins denses d'initiatives privées les
zones
cette situation est problématique car
cela prive certains de nos concitoyens
du bénéfice de la fibre
pour rappel amis signifie appel à
manifestation d'intention d'investir il
s'agit donc bien d'engagement librement
consentis par les opérateurs concernés
certains d'entre vous s'en souviennent
ce choix a d'ailleurs été fait à
l'encontre de la volonté de certaines
collectivités d'assurer le déploiement
de ces communes parce que c'était les
plus rentables cette situation est aussi
problématique car cela fragilise la
trajectoire de fermeture du réseau
cuivre
vous l'avez noté monsieur le Président
nous avons donc mis en demeure en mars
dernier orange de respecter les
engagements pris auprès du gouvernement
c'est-à-dire de couvrir 100% des locaux
de la zone amie Orange dont au plus 8%
en raccordable à la demande orange
d'abord contesté cette décision de mise
en demeure devant le Conseil d'État
considérant notamment avoir pris un
engagement sur un volume de ligne à
déployer au sens d'indicateurs
statistiques Insee daté
dans les faits la lecture des
engagements d'orange ne laisse aucun
doute quant à la nature réelle de
l'engagement pris il s'agit d'un
engagement de couverture d'une liste de
commune qui doit être complète à une
date donnée c'est d'ailleurs aussi ainsi
que l'on comprit toutes les
collectivités concernées plus récemment
et c'est dans la presse d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui comme vous l'avez aussi
noté monsieur le Président alors je me
permets d'en parler orange à déposer une
demande de questions prioritaire ou de
constitutionnalité d'une part sur le
pouvoir de sanctions de la recette mais
aussi sur la constitutionnalité de
l'article l33 13 du Code des postes de
communication électronique cet article
l33 13 est justement la base juridique
rendant ses engagements pris auprès du
gouvernement juridiquement opposable en
procédant ainsi Orange demande au
Conseil d'État de transmettre la QPC au
Conseil constitutionnel et ainsi de
surseoir
sur la mise en demeure de la recette
dans l'attente de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel en réalité ce qu'on
range cherche à faire avec ces questions
prioritaires de constitutionnalité c'est
un minima gagné du temps par rapport à
ces engagements c'est retarder la
décision du Conseil d'État sur la mise
en demeure elle-même voire que le
Conseil d'État ne soit jamais en demeure
de se prononcer sur le fond qui soit
dans l'incapacité juridique de confirmer
la mise en demeure de la recette
que doit-on comprendre de toutes ces
démarches doit-on comprendre que les
engagements d'orange pris devant le
gouvernement n'avaient pas de valeur en
qu'aurange renie ses engagements
breton comprendre que de nombreux
habitants des Sables-d'Olonne de La
Roche-sur-Yon de la bride de
Brive-la-Gaillarde et de bien d'autres
communes en zone ami orange vont devoir
attendre encore longtemps la fibre
doit-on comprendre qu'au range défi les
objectifs à signer à la régulation par
la volonté du Parlement
doit-on comprendre enfin qu'au orange
préfère plutôt que viser l'atteinte des
objectifs qui s'étaient lui-même fixé en
2018 tenter d'arracher son sifflet au
gendarme des télécoms
la stratégie d'orange sur ses
déploiements en zone amie à l'aube de la
fermeture du réseau cuivre reste un
mystère
pour revenir à vos questions monsieur le
Président sur le plan de fermeture du
réseau cuivre son succès reposera aussi
dans la mise en place effective par
Orange d'une gouvernance associant
réellement toutes les parties prenantes
et dans un esprit de parfaite
concertation avec l'opérateur
d'infrastructures de la zone bien sûr
mais aussi avec tous les opérateurs
commerciaux et les collectivités
concernées j'aimerais d'ailleurs qu'au
range s'appuie davantage sur les
propositions faites par les
collectivités dans le choix des communes
à fermer il serait préférable en effet
commencer par les communes et les élus
les plus motivés cela faciliterait
grandement les opérations
de plus orange doit partager beaucoup
plus les informations qu'il a notamment
celle permettant de réconcilier les
adresses de présence du réseau cuivre
avec celle du réseau fibre de
l'opérateur d'infrastructures et ceci
afin de permettre une substitution
des deux réseaux enfin il faut veiller à
ce qu'une communication neutre et
rassurant soit assuré vis-à-vis des
Français concernés par la fermeture du
réseau cuivre
enfin dernier point que je souhaiterais
aborder en question en propos liminaire
et non des moindres c'est la prise en
compte des enjeux environnementaux du
numérique au sein des travaux de la
recette
comme le mentionne le rapport du Sénat
réalisé en 2021 l'empreinte carbone du
numérique représente 2% de l'empreinte
totale en France aujourd'hui cela peut
paraître peu mais sa croissance est
exponentielle du fait de la
multiplication des usages du numérique
et des terminaux connectés il nous
paraît donc essentiel que le secteur du
numérique qui peut par des services
innovants contribués à apporter des
solutions face aux enjeux climatiques ne
s'exonère pas pour autant des efforts à
faire pour réduire lui-même son
empreinte c'est pour cela que l'ARCEP a
ouvert un nouveau chapitre de la
régulation avec la prise en compte des
enjeux environnementaux du numérique
en 2020 le gouvernement a confié à
l'ADEME et larsep une mission pour
mesurer l'empreinte environnementale du
numérique et faire un exercice de
prospective à échéance de 2030 et 2050
nous avons remis les conclusions notre
étude hors travail sur la partie
prospective l'année dernière voici
quelques éléments tirés quelques
enseignements tirés de l'étude
des trois composantes du numérique qui
constituent le périmètre de l'étude ce
sont les terminaux et en particulier les
écrans et les téléviseurs qui sont à
l'origine de 65 à 90% de l'impact
environnemental selon l'indicateur est
considéré parmi tous les impacts
environnementaux l'épuisement des
ressources énergétiques fossiles
l'empreinte carbone les radiations
ionisantes liées à la consommation
énergétique ainsi que l'épuisement des
ressources abiotiques minéraux et métaux
ressortent comme des impacts
prédominants du numérique
de toutes les étapes du cycle de vie des
biens et services considérés la phase de
fabrication et la principale source
d'impact suivi de la phase d'utilisation
concentrant souvent à L2 jusqu'à 100% de
l'impact environnemental selon
l'indicateur environnemental considéré
l'étude confirme le besoin d'approfondir
la connaissance sur ce sujet de
collecter des données et de permettre à
terme l'ouverture de base de données
publiques sur la question
elle confirme aussi la nécessité d'agir
sur l'impact environnemental des
équipements et matériels notamment
favorisant l'allongement de la durée
d'usage des équipements numériques par
de meilleures réparabilités durabilité
par le développement du
reconditionnement ou de la réparation
mais l'étude réafym aussi
l'interdépendance entre les réseaux les
centres données et les terminaux et donc
vous suffit des actions pour limiter
l'impact environnemental du numérique
dans tous les domaines du numérique
grâce à la proposition de loi du Sénat
la loi reine 2 votée en décembre 2021
notre collègue de données
environnementale est élargi à l'ensemble
des acteurs du numérique et viendra
progressivement enrichir notre enquête
annuelle pour un numérique soutenable
ces résultats vont nous donner une
vision inédite de l'empreinte
environnementale du numérique afin
d'informer les citoyens les acteurs
publics et l'ensemble des partis
prenantes sur les impacts mais aussi
d'identifier les activités des acteurs
susceptibles d'avoir un véritable impact
sur l'environnement et ainsi ciblé les
actions vers les mesures les plus
efficaces en matière d'impact
environnemental nous voulons aussi
suivre l'évolution de ces indicateurs
dans le temps pour permettre une
évaluation objective des politiques
publiques sur le numérique
et je finis mes propos liminaires pour
vous assurer
de mon engagement de l'engagement de
l'ensemble des membres du collège de
tous les arts septiennes et les acéiens
à défendre les objectifs d'intérêt
général et les priorités politiques que
vous nous fixez par la loi sur
l'ensemble des secteurs que nous
régulons avec en ligne de mire en
boussole la satisfaction des
utilisateurs je vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente pour pour
vous proposer un peu vos réponses sur
sur
un certain nombre de sujets je permets
de rappeler quand même que notre
commission a été la première à faire un
rapport d'information
ce rapport d'information de juin
2020 sur l'empreinte numérique à
l'initiative de Patrick chaise et dont
les corps-à-porteurs étaient Jean-Michel
Houlgate et Guillaume chevrolier je
pense que ce rapport était très
important j'ai un grand nombre de
demandes de parole
pour ne rien vous cacher 15 donc je vais
faire des séries de 5
et vous répondrez à l'issue des séries
de cinq questions ça vous va alors je
vais donner la parole à Jean-Michel
Houlgate
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente donc bienvenue au Sénat donc
je souhaite à mon tour aux interroger
sur trois sujets concernant le plan
France très haut débit tout d'abord la
couverture en fibre optique en zone très
dense alors que cette zone et vous
l'avez rappelé et couverte environ 90 %,
il faut noter que certains départements
affichent des taux de couverture qui eux
sont très inférieurs à la moyenne
notamment la Meurthe-et-Moselle et le
Nord qui ne sont couverts qu'à 70% on
observe en outre une forte baisse des
déploiements dans cette zone alors
comment expliquer ces incomplétude de
déploiement dans une zone qui est
pourtant considérée comme
commercialement rentable pour les
opérateurs s'il s'avère que l'initiative
privée est finalement insuffisante pour
atteindre les objectifs de déploiement
dans certaines zones de la dans certains
endroits secteurs de la zone très dense
ne faudrait-il pas organiser de nouveaux
appels à manifestation d'intérêt pour
les identifier et ils prévoient des
engagements contraignants pour les
opérateurs je souhaite également
rebondir sur les propos du président
pour aborder un effet de bord de la
fermeture du réseau cuivre étant donné
qu'au orange n'est plus tenu d'étendre
son réseau cuivre les occupants de
logement neufs dans de nouveaux
lotissement notamment qui ne sont pas
encore raccordés à la fibre se trouve
dans l'impossibilité de souscrire à une
offre de réseau fixe et non pas d'autres
alternatives que de recourir à la 4G
mobile avez-vous été alerté sur ce sujet
qui est un peu ubuesque et quelle
réponse faudrait-il y apporter enfin je
souhaite évoquer comme vous l'avez fait
donc la qualité du raccordement final
des abonnés à la fibre sujet qui revêt
donc une importance particulière pour
bien évidemment favoriser
l'acceptabilité de la fermeture du
réseau cuivre et la transition complète
de la DSL vers le FTTH pouvez-vous nous
faire un état d'avancement sur les
mesures qui ont été mises en place sous
l'égide de l'arceb vous l'avez déjà en
partie déployer mais notamment pour
encadrer ce fameux mode stock en
particulier la généralisation d'un
nouveau contrat de raccordement puis
vous l'avez également souligné notre
collègue Patrick Chaize a récemment
déposé une proposition de loi notamment
l'élaboration par l'opérateur
d'infrastructure d'un cahier des charges
qui en cas de les conditions de
réalisation du raccordement le texte
propose également de renforcer les
pouvoirs de sanction de larcep alors
quel est votre regard sur les
propositions faites par notre collègue
Patrick chaise
merci chers collègues je vous donne la
parole à Madame demain
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente je vous ai bien écouté tout
au long de
cette allocution préliminaire et je me
pose une question au final que
devons-nous comprendre
que devons-nous comprendre quand au
déploiement de la fibre sur les
territoires reste à couvrir que
devons-nous comprendre quant au
décomissionnements du cuivre par rapport
à l'opérateur et quels sont les moyens
réellement à la disposition de la
recette pour pouvoir atteindre
l'objectif tout fibre à l'horizon 2025
parce que c'est bien là la question
comment contraindre l'opérateur à
j'allais dire
être conforme aux engagements pris par
l'État et quels sont aujourd'hui les
moyens dont on dispose pour pouvoir
atteindre l'objectif
revenons sur le plan de
décomissionnement du cuivre moi je
voulais vous poser des questions
peut-être complémentaires à celle de mon
collège mais quels sont les dispositions
aujourd'hui prévues par lacep pour
optimiser fluidifier le processus de des
commissions au niveau local en
particulier quelle est la maille de
fermeture technique peut-être la plus la
plus opportune elle se la commune ou
est-ce peut-être dans les zones plus
denses ou dans les zones très denses à
l'échelle du quartier est-ce que c'est
une possibilité quelles sont surtout
madame la Présidente les mesures qui
sont retenues pour assurer de la
transparence d'orange et les sanctions
éventuelles auxquelles il pourrait
s'exposer s'il ne tient pas ces
engagements notamment en termes
d'accompagnement des administrés et du
maintien du service un parcelle parce
que c'est bien là la question et puis en
amont du plan de déconditionnement il y
a aussi la complitude des déploiements
ceux qui vont rester les plus difficiles
les raccordements complexes l'habitat
isolé les zones blanches en zone très
dense que prévoit la recette afin
d'assurer l'accès au très haut débit
d'ici 2025 pour ses cas particuliers
aussi et puis enfin je rejoindrai aussi
les constats qui sont faits au niveau
local
l'opacité sur le calendrier de
déploiement en zone ami quelles sont les
moyens dont on disposeront les communes
pour avoir cette transparence au final
quels sont aujourd'hui les possibilités
qui sont les nôtres au regard d'un
opérateur qui a
semble-t-il oublié les engagements
d'origine mais
que va-t-on faire pour obtenir le 100%
fibre à l'horizon 2025 alors même que
l'État s'est engagé sur le sujet
merci
chers collègues
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
madame présidente chez trois questions à
vous poser je voudrais d'abord vous
parler encore et toujours des hommes
blanches qui malgré les années qui
passent sont loin d'être résolus et ce
malgré la multiplication des pylônes de
téléphonie provoquant d'ailleurs plus de
mécontentement chez nos concitoyens que
de solutions leurs problèmes de
connexion au réseau dans le village j'ai
à nouveau alerté le ministre en charge
des télécommunications à ce propos en
l'appelant à une action politique
volontariste et ferme de mutualisation
des relais téléphoniques qu'en
pensez-vous madame la Présidente c'est
ma première question
ces hommes blanches synonyme de fracture
territoriales m'amène à mon deuxième
sujet depuis le 1er janvier les Français
ont dit au revoir au timbre rouge
désormais l'envoi du courrier
prioritaire se fera donc en ligne en
scannant ces documents sur le site de la
poste de plus en plus de démarches se
font sur Internet télétravail
téléconsultation déclarations des impôts
Excel à la culture et j'en passe mais là
aussi la République numérique perd des
citoyens en cours de route
54% des Français éprouvent vous le savez
au moins une forme de difficulté les
empêchant d'effectuer des démarches en
ligne sans internet sans ordinateur et
le plus souvent d'ailleurs
l'appréhension de cette pratique
numérique limite l'accessibilité à ses
services qu'en pensez-vous et quel est
votre action dans ce domaine c'est ma
deuxième question et enfin troisième
question extrêmement rapide nous vous
avions reçu ici le 24 mars 2021 et je
vous avais alerté sur la difficulté que
nous avions à nous connecter au niveau
ferroviaire sur la ligne Amiens pareil
qui est une des lignes les plus
importantes de France on ne peut pas
travailler puisqu'on n'a pas d'accès via
orange en tout cas euh aussi Internet et
vous m'aviez répondu à l'époque que vous
alliez donc intervenir auprès de la SNCF
pour avoir des informations sur le sujet
est-ce que cela a été fait et si oui
quelle est la réponse merci
chers
ville merci monsieur le Président merci
et madame la Présidente pour votre
exposé luminaire alors j'aurais deux
petites questions la première question
c'est sur le la distribution du courrier
et des quotidiens
donc quand on reçoit un journal par la
poste bien il se trouve qu'on ne le
reçoit pas tous les jours donc elle
est-ce que c'est un sujet qui va
s'éteindre puisque de moins en moins de
gens sont peut-être abonnés je n'en sais
rien mais comment peut-on faire pour
quand on est abonné recevoir son journal
tous les jours puisque ça n'est pas le
cas
d'autre part sur le développement de la
fimo bon il se trouve que lors de mes
visites communales j'ai plusieurs fois
dans certaines communes eu des
témoignages assez
assez édifiant sur le développement et
la sous-traitance notamment que des
communes ont donc des trappes dans la
avec des câbles visiblement des fils à
l'air libre avec des travaux qui ont
commencé qui ne se terminent pas avec
des des habitants qui ont de l'Internet
qui fluctue un jour ils en ont d'autres
ils n'en ont pas et sur le fait de ne
pas avoir d'interlocuteurs c'est à dire
quand personne ne répond quels sont les
recours possibles et comment peut-on
faire quand on constate
cette installation très chaotique voilà
dans dans une commune quels sont les
recours que peuvent avoir les maires par
exemple je vous remercie
dernière intervenant pour cette série de
questions et rigole
merci président madame la Présidente
je reprends un peu la question de
Stéphane Demilly même dans sa dernière
enquête en partenariat avec la Défenseur
des droits l'UFC Que Choisir pointe et
difficultés d'accès des citoyens au
service public entre numéro injoignable
renvoie perpétuel vers des sites
Internet ce constat me pousse à parler
encore de la suppression du timbre rouge
au profit de la île lettre rouge
désormais pour envoyer une lettre
prioritaire il faut soit la rédiger sur
le site de la Poste soit se rendre dans
un bureau de poste pour la rédiger sur
place cette disposition est pénalisante
pour bon nombre de concitoyens qui sont
ou éloignés du numérique ou éloignés des
bureaux de poste une fois de plus la
dématérialisation produit de l'exclusion
cette numérisation des démarches
administratives et bien sûr un progrès à
condition toutefois qu'elle s'accompagne
de canaux alternatifs vous avez dans vos
missions la lutte contre la contre toute
forme d'entrave qui pourrait menacer la
liberté d'échanger donc à travers
l'exemple du timbre rouge je
souhaiterais savoir si à vos yeux le
nécessaire accès au service public
postal et maintenu pour tous et puis
deuxième question qui est un peu
différente même si je sais pas si elle
rentre dans votre périmètre d'action et
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
d'empreintes environnementales du
numérique et d'épuisement des ressources
donc moi ma question elle va porter sur
l'avenir du cuivre qui reste chez les
particuliers après la pose de la fibre
lorsque un opérateur installe
physiquement le câble fibre dans les
fourreaux le technicien laisse le câble
cuivre alors que théoriquement il n'a
plus d'utilité alors les modèles
économiques sont parfois compliqués à
équilibrer ne serait-il donc pas
possible de collecter le cuivre pour
qu'il soit ou valorisé ou recycler
merci chers collègues je vais vous
donner la parole madame la Présidente
j'ai
omis de saluer la présence de notre
collègue Patrick chaise que je salue
merci beaucoup
merci question il y a eu plusieurs
questions sur
sur le déploiement de la fibre en fait
et sur la teinte des objectifs que ça
soit en zone très dense en zone RIP en
zonami d'ici 2025 avant la fermeture
du réseau cuivre la première question
était sur la couverture en zone très
dense oui c'est les zones très denses
ont été difficiles et environ 7 millions
de locaux en France et ils ont été
définis là avec une concurrence par les
infrastructures et donc il y a pas des
obligations réglementaires de
déploiement et c'est vrai qu'on constate
notamment dans certaines zones très
denses un taux qui est pas du tout près
de 100%
et cela pose vraiment des questions et
on a les mêmes je dirais questionnement
ce
ce qui serait possible c'est qu'il y ait
une reprise en main en fait de certaines
zones très denses soit par un autre
opérateur soit par une collectivité
après une démarche par exemple de
constat de carence cette question est
parfaitement légitime ensunami sur les
zones amies oranges je crois que j'ai
expliqué la situation on avait mis en
demeure et pour tout vous dire c'est
même le gouvernement qui nous a demandé
d'ouvrir une procédure de sanction on a
étudié la demande du gouvernement on a
mis en demeure orange de respecter ses
engagements en 2022 et donc orange a
contesté cette mise en demeure devant le
Conseil d'État à la date limite
quasiment du fin de l'instruction par le
Conseil d'État orange dépose enfin
demande une
QPC une question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité
directement sur l'article 33 16 qui rend
ses obligations juridiquement opposables
donc orange gagne du temps et
voilà moi j'ai tant que cette situation
juristique est pas débloquée
j'ai la recette n'a pas d'autre moyen
que
le Conseil d'État
rendent des décisions sur ce sujet
cette situation nous préoccupe bien
évidemment parce que derrière comme je
l'ai dit encore ce sont des citoyens qui
n'ont pas la fibre et on ne s'aligne pas
aussi sur le plan de fermeture du réseau
cuivre et ça laisse en fait orange
décidé selon son bon vouloir quand
est-ce qu'il va finir de déployer les
communes les communes en question
sur les sur les zones RIP
le déploiement se passe
bien généralement dans les collectivités
et la plupart c'est là où on voit le
plus grand dynamisme de déploiement
aujourd'hui
de la fibre et il y a aussi pour être
honnête on avait mis en demeure aussi
XP fibre de
exactement savoir sa voix connectée de
déployer de tenir ses excusez-moi on
avait mis sa voix connectée
en demeure de respecter ces engagements
sur les zonamelles et on voit que
XP fibre
avance dans les déploiements et idem
pour pour l'autre département qui est la
Nièvre la Nièvre on avait mis en demeure
ni avenue numérique c'est-à-dire SFR de
respecter ses engagements à mails et là
on voit en revanche que
SFR déploie donc ça avance on est
vigilant et on surveille naturellement
l'avancée de ces déploiements comme
l'avancée de tous les autres
déploiements
sur il y a une question sur le
déploiement de la fibre concernant les
nouveaux locaux
les nouveaux locaux si le point de
mutualisation c'est à dire l'armoire de
rue a été placée c'est à l'opérateur
d'infrastructures de réaliser le
raccordement
c'est très clair il le savent alors
quelquefois ils sont en retard parce que
ils ont pas toujours été mis dans la
boucle et ils connaissent pas aussi bien
que nous connaissez orange les
procédures administratives d'urbanisme
mais c'est à l'opérateur
d'infrastructures de réaliser le
raccordement du nouveau local si on est
dans un territoire qui n'est pas encore
fibré c'est à Orange de
d'assurer le raccordement le
raccordement dans ce cas là au réseau
cuivre parce que il y a pas encore
d'infrastructures de réseau fibre
concernant pareil sur la fibre et sur
les enjeux de qualité de service j'en ai
parlé pas mal dans ma dans mes propos
liminaires mais il y a une question
concernant la PPL chaise et le l'article
qui concerne le renfort des pouvoirs de
la recette je suis évidemment très
favorable à cet article qui donne plus
de pouvoir à la recette en matière
notamment de une capacité à réaliser des
audits sur la qualité de service à la
charge des opérateurs donc
voilà sur
[Musique]
concernant la fermeture du réseau cuivre
j'ai eu plusieurs questions aussi sur ce
sujet là alors pour moi les facteurs
clés de succès de la fermeture du réseau
cuivre il repose sur un il faut un
réseau Phi préalable de qualité
2 il faut vraiment associer les parties
prenantes mais je dirais vraiment
associé les parties prenantes notamment
dans le choix des communes et donc les
collectivités dans le choix des communes
et s'assurer que les j'irai de prendre
en priorité les communes qui sont
moteurs et aujourd'hui je reçois des
courriers et je pense que Orange leur
soit aussi et je pense que l'État
décentralisé c'était d'aller préfectures
les reçoivent aussi de communes qui sont
candidates à la fermeture du réseau
culot ou départements qui sont combinés
parce que un maximum de communes du
département puisse faire partie des
premiers lots je dis à Orange prenez
d'abord ces communes ça me paraît
en tout cas ces facteurs de réussite
deuxièmement il faut aussi une
mobilisation très forte d'orange sur ce
projet et donc des mots la mise en
oeuvre de moyens associés à la conduite
du projet à la fois au niveau national
et sur tous les territoires
conséquentes parce que c'est un projet
structurant pour la filiation
à mener pour Orange et que pour que ça
soit bien réussi et pour que il y a
l'association de tous il faut que mettre
les moyens associés à l'ampleur de ce
projet il faut aussi assurer une
communication vis-à-vis des personnes
concernées alors ça vaut pour Orange
mais ça vaut pour tous les opérateurs
commerciaux et puis à un moment donné
quand ça deviendra non plus des lots de
la phase de transition mais une qu'on
rentrera dans une phase plus générale je
pense qu'il faudra un accompagnement
aussi d'une communication publique sur
ce sur ce projet
[Musique]
il y a eu une question aussi sur les les
RAKO complexes les raccordements
complexes et les raccordements longs
aujourd'hui c'est à l'opérateur
d'infrastructures de réaliser le ghisnie
civil manquant sur le domaine public
quelquefois les raccordements sont
difficiles à cause de travaux à faire en
zone privée et donc là c'est à aux
particuliers enfin c'est à la personne
privée qu'elle soit entreprise ou
particulier de réaliser les travaux sur
la sur le domaine privé mais pour tout
le domaine public c'est à l'opérateur
d'infrastructures de réaliser ses
travaux
[Musique]
et dans
dans une
consultation publique qu'on vient de
lancer sur ce sujet on a dit qu'il
n'était pas déraisonnable de ce qu'elle
a
on pourrait envisager en fait que
les tarifs de génie civil construit soit
intégré dans le tarif facturé entre le
point de branchement et le point de
mutualisation donc on est en
consultation publique naturellement tous
les acteurs sont pas forcément alignés
avec cette proposition mais on peut
raisonnable en fait que Loïc puisse
recouvrer une partie de ses coups quand
il y a des travaux à faire qui sont
complexes et des travaux de génie civil
en particulier
pour changer de sujet et parler des
sujets postaux avec le timbre rouge
et la suppression du timbre rouge nous
avons rendu un avis sur ce sujet et sur
l'ensemble de la gamme tarifaire alors
juste pour pour
l'ensemble de la gamme tarifaire
aujourd'hui
80 ou 85 % des envois réalisés par les
Français sont par le biais de la lettre
verte la lettre verte avant c'était une
distribution en J+2 aujourd'hui dans la
nouvelle gamme tarifaire
centrée sur sur la lettre verte c'est
une distribution en J + 3 donc on peut
dire dans ce cadre là que le service
universel majoritairement utilisé par
les Français et maintenus par le biais
de la lettre verte certainement la Poste
a souhaité
conserver la possibilité d'avoir une
distribution en J plus un
comme l'objectif du de ce changement de
tarifaire est une réduction des coûts du
service universel postal et je vous
expliquais la différence la différence
aujourd'hui de coups c'est 1,6 milliards
de coût net du service universel la
console compensation qui a été votée par
la loi c'est 520 millions et donc le
lancement de la nouvelle gamme
l'objectif de ce lancement c'est de
faire des réductions de coûts et donc un
des moyens de
la réduction de coûts souhaité par par
la poste c'était de dématérialiser en
fait la lettre prioritaire sur une
partie du trajet ce que nous avons fait
dans notre avis c'est que nous avons
demandé nous avons demandé alerté en
fait la poste sur le fait qu'il fallait
accompagner avec beaucoup de
communication le lancement de cette
nouvelle gamme et de s'assurer aussi
c'est ce que met en place la poste que
chaque personne peut être accompagnée
sur cette illette rouge prioritaire et
donc dans tous les bureaux de poste vous
avez normalement des facteurs qui sont
formés et pour pouvoir faire les
démarches avec la personne qui voudrait
utiliser ce service je pense que c'est
extrêmement important que ça soit sur ce
service là ou que ça soit sur d'autres
qu'on veille avec une grande attention à
tous les dispositifs qu'on met en place
pour l'inclusion numérique donc je
partage complètement votre alerte je dis
que la poste le met en place parce que
vous pouvez le faire dans les bureaux de
poste on peut aussi imaginer que ça
pourrait être fait en complément aussi
dans des maisons françaises par exemple
puisque c'est un des objectifs France
services mais c'est un enjeu politique
majeur que de réfléchir à chaque fois à
l'impact en matière d'inclusion
numérique et dernier point sur
les autres blanches nous sommes nous
avons publié dès 2016 des lignes
directrices concernant la mutualisation
des réseaux mobiles et nous sommes
favorables à la mutualisation des
pylônes très favorables et d'ailleurs je
l'ai dit dans le New Deal dans ce cas
dans ce cadre-là était une bonne
politique publique parce que on a sur
les
1787 sites qui ont été mises en service
au 30 décembre au 30 septembre 2022 plus
de 90% qui sont mutualisés à quatre
opérateurs donc non seulement c'est bien
d'un point de vue esthétique mais en
plus ça apporte un service cohérent pour
pour les Français qui n'ont pas à
changer d'opérateur quand ils changent
de zone
merci je vais donner la parole à
Guillaume Chevrollier
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la Présidente je voulais évoquer
également la proposition de loi
d'initiative sénatoriale du président
chaise ici présent d'ailleurs sur la
réduction de l'empreinte
environnementale du numérique on vous
avez déjà évoqué un point sur le rôle
central de l'Arsène bien sûr sur la le
plan de la régulation environnementale
du numérique avec ce pouvoir qui vous a
été confié de collecter des données donc
vous avez déjà répondu en partie à cette
question sur sur la mise en oeuvre de
cette nouvelle compétence la seconde
question
qui concerne aussi une disposition de la
Loire in c'est sur la lutte contre le
démarchage téléphonique alors c'est vrai
que sur le terrain on est interpellé en
permanence sur les problèmes de
démarchage abusive qui est exaspère nos
concitoyens
mais il y avait un point qui avait été
identifié donc au niveau de l'article 24
et qui permettait à la recette
d'interdire l'usage de certains
indicateurs géographiques au système
automatisé d'appel néanmoins il
semblerait que des effets indésirables
soient constatés sur des secteurs
d'activité qui n'étaient pas a priori
dans le viseur du législateur notamment
les sondages d'opinion ou la gestion des
relations clientes donc nous avions
identifié ce risque lors de l'examen en
deuxième lecture en octobre 2021
mais la volonté d'adopter le texte
confort n'avait pas permis d'opérer de
correction sur cet article introduit par
l'Assemblée nationale puisqu'on
souhaitait inconfort afin de mettre en
oeuvre cette proposition de loi donc
avez-vous été alerté et
identifier vous aujourd'hui des
solutions pour remédier à cette
difficulté par la voix réglementaire ou
à travers un ajustement du plan de
numérotation de la recette
donc je voulais également comme un
certain nombre de mes collègues profiter
de cette audition pour vous alerter
comme on est interpellé régulièrement
par nos élus locaux sur le terrain sur
les la persistance de zone blanche
malgré le déploiement et les effets
positifs du New Deal mais on a un
certain nombre de communes je pourrais
en faire une liste assez complète mais
enfin je pense après d'Anjou saint
Thomas de courseuriers ils sont je pense
après l'Anjou où il y a eu
l'installation par exemple d'une antenne
téléphonique mais il n'y a qu'un seul
opérateur donc ce qui pose des problèmes
puisque la population enfin il y a pour
peine nommer il y a free mais il y a pas
orange donc les élus sont interpellés
parce que une partie de la population
n'est pas chez cette opérateur donc il y
a l'antenne mais il y a pas la
couverture il y a également les
interpellations de d'élus sur les
problèmes de qualité du réseau cuivre
donc vous avez indiqué qu'il fallait
agir pour la qualité du réseau cuivre et
le respect des obligations par Orange
mais voilà peut que vous relayez une
insatisfaction des élus de nos
concitoyens sur le terrain des délais
d'intervention qui ne sont absolument
pas satisfaisants
et le dernier point je voulais aborder
avec vous une proposition de loi que je
viens de déposer qui permettrait de
garantir une meilleure information dans
le cadre des installations d'antenne
relais en substance cette proposition de
loi permettrait de transférer la
responsabilité de l'information aux
administrés concernés par l'installation
d'une antenne relais de l'élu aux
opérateurs
en effet assez incohérent que le maire
ou le président de le PCI n'ayant aucun
pouvoir pour empêcher les installations
d'antenne soit en charge de
l'information
aux habitants de l'implantation d'une
antenne donc de plus cette situation
l'esplanner parfois une incompréation de
la part des habitants sur les pouvoirs
des élus en la matière donc est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
proposition de loi je vous remercie
merci chers collègues Nadège avait
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente dans le cadre de vos travaux
en faveur d'un numérique soutenable la
collecte de données environnementales a
été élargi aux opérateurs des Data
Center et de communication électronique
ainsi qu'au fabricants de terminaux donc
en décembre dernier pourriez-vous nous
préciser le type de données collectées
en plus de celle concernant les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre il y
aura-t-il des éléments sur les appareils
reconditionnés notamment et
pourriez-vous nous préciser le
calendrier de la
publications pardon de ces résultats
merci la parole est à Didier mandeli oui
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente moi j'ai deux sujets mais qui
ont été largement d'ailleurs abordés par
mes collègues notamment Stéphane de
millet et Guillaume Chevrier à l'instant
pour le premier d'entre eux il s'agit
des de la mutualisation des antennes
relais je vais déposé il y a quelques
mois une proposition de loi que j'ai les
séances sommeil puisque un salon de
disposition que j'avais prévu ont été
reprise dans le cadre du de l'excellent
texte de notre excellent collègue
président chaise
parce que les élus effectivement sont
tout à fait démunies et pas du tout
associé et moi je j'avais rédigé cette
proposition de loi en réaction à
plusieurs implantations en Vendée
notamment sur la commune de
Saint-Hilaire-de-Riez commune du
littoral font face à un afflux important
l'été et on surdimensionne les
équipements pour faire face évidemment à
cette afflux de population estivale et
sur un semestre cinq projets différents
d'opérateurs différents sur la même
commune sans aucune concertation
actualisation donc le New Deal a réglé
une partie des choses mais pour le reste
ce n'était pas réglé donc vous avez noté
effectivement tout à l'heure quelques
améliorations sur le sujet ensuite sur
le raccordement des zonami ou laver
évoqué également et vous avez d'ailleurs
cité les deux villes vendéennes
concernées les Sables-d'Olonne et La
Roche-sur-Yon c'est un peu plus de
100000 prises au foyer ou locaux
raccordables à peine
75% sont aujourd'hui raccordés alors que
la convention précisé que c'était 100% à
2020 vous l'avez évoqué voilà la
question que je me pose alors l'argument
de orange sur le sujet c'est de dire que
quand le contrat était signé il y avait
une population définie mais il se trouve
que la Vendée comme d'autres est un
département qui se développe et
notamment sur la zone littorale et que
donc n'ont pas été prises en compte les
nouveaux habitants on en gagne 7500 on
Vendée par an donc et donc on en est là
aujourd'hui moi la question que je pose
sur le sujet sujet c'est très
précisément est-ce que une collectivité
dans la mesure où le reste du
département est couvert par une
structure qui s'appelle Vendée numérique
est un réseau d'initiatives publiques
qui est délégué orange d'ailleurs
est-ce que les collectivités ont la
capacité juridiquement aujourd'hui à
dénoncer les contrats et à travailler
avec avec l'autre l'autre partie du
département qui est bientôt couverte à
100%
pour la fille
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
selon l'Observatoire du très haut débit
000 locaux sont difficilement
raccordables en raison des coûts élevés
pour la construction des prises moi je
voudrais parler à un instant de notre
département des Alpes-Maritimes avec
Patricia dema et des vallées sinistrés
de la Roya de la Tinée de la Vésubie par
la tempête Alex que la Commission a
d'ailleurs visité malgré les efforts du
département des Alpes-Maritimes de
l'ordre de 165 millions d'euros 2000 à
2500 prises pourraient être abandonnés
par rapport aux difficultés d'accès vous
l'imaginez c'est compliqué d'entendre ça
pour des territoires qui ont déjà
beaucoup souffert donc ma question est
simple à ce que l'ARCEP est susceptible
de travailler avec le gouvernement pour
élaborer un plan spécial pour financer
la construction de ses prises isolées
merci la parole est à Monsieur
madame la Présidente
bienvenue d'abord à vous et à toute
votre toute votre équipe sur nos
territoires et je vais prendre l'exemple
de l'Eure-et-Loir vous l'avez dit n'est
pas une semaine sans que nous ne soyons
interpellés
tant par les élus que par des
concitoyens sur un problème qui si je
peux me permettre relève purement du
service après-vente c'est ainsi que en
Eure-et-Loir ce sont multipliés
publiquement les témoignages des
communes du territoire du Perche que
vous connaissez bien quand il ne s'agit
pas d'une fibre coupée par un engin de
travaux sur une route départementale
c'est le remplacement impossible d'un
poteau tombé par grand vent aux usé par
le temps portant le triangle jaune d'un
boîtier heurter lors d'un accident de
voiture dans un village où la repose
d'un câble ballon bref au final
l'utilisateur à qui l'on a vendu le
produit idéal de communication tant pour
son téléphone mobile son ordinateur sa
tablette que sa télévision se retrouve
cette fois-ci dans une blanche absolue
et dans l'isolement le plus complet voir
dans un isolement dangereux quand il
s'agit d'une personne
âgée qui bénéficie d'un système de
surveillance ou d'assistance connectée
sans parler de celles et ceux à qui
l'État les entreprises ont vendu le
télétravail puisque les exemples que je
vous donne dans mon propos on l'a
particularité de se situe un milieu
rural en les maires ne ménage jamais
leurs efforts sur les territoires ils
agissent au mieux pour sécuriser les
lieux lors d'un accident avec leur
maigre moyen c'est-à-dire leurs employés
communaux et leurs concitoyens
agriculteurs parfois même avec l'aide
des gendarmes de la Régale locale
puisqu'il déclare comme il se doivent
les incidents sur la miraculeuse
plateforme de l'opérateur et ce sont
aucun interlocuteur au bout du fil
puisque nous sommes entrés dans une
société connectée la décision du
déplacement de la fibre sur les poteaux
ça a été dit téléphonique et la
diversité des opérateurs est trop
souvent ressentie comme une véritable
catastrophe par les populations
impactées par les par les alors ma
question madame la Présidente est la
suivante dans ces exemples
il ne s'agit pas d'heure ou de jours
mais de semaine voire de moi sans aucun
moyen de communication pour nos
concitoyens et cela sans compter sur les
arguments opposés aux élus locaux par
les opérateurs pour retarder les
interventions sous-traitant des
faillants liquidation judiciaires
d'éclairage administrative de travaux
d'autorisation d'arrêter de voirie avant
que la technicien puisse programmer
alors la recette à laquelle à la tête de
laquelle vous vous trouvez que vous
représentez est-elle en mesure
aujourd'hui d'imposer davantage aux
différents opérateurs dans le cadre d'un
SAV PERFORMANT vous y avez en partie
répondu que tout soit bien mis en oeuvre
pour que des travaux efficaces et ceux
dans des délais raisonnables avec des
règles d'intervention très clair voire
très strictes s'agissant des travaux de
maintenance des réseaux répondent ainsi
avec professionnalisme un siècle où tout
est connecté merci madame la Présidente
madame la Présidente je vous propose de
répondre à mes collègues avant de vous
donner une dernière série de cette
question
si pour toutes ces questions je vais
commencer par la question concernant le
démarchage
téléphonique alors il faut être clair la
recette n'a pas de compétences sur le
démarchage téléphonique on a des
compétences sur les plans de
numérotation
et donc on a encadré les usages
exactement comme vous l'avez dit
Monsieur chevrolier de certains numéros
par exemple on a dit que sur les numéros
mobiles 06 07 ça devait être uniquement
des appels interpersonnels donc il n'y a
plus de démarchage téléphonique
typiquement sur ce par un automate
d'appel sur ce type de numéro donc ça on
a cette capacité de définir
les numérostations et comme quels usages
doivent être fait de ces numérostations
mais on n'a pas de compétences sur les
marchés téléphoniques donc on n'a pas de
moyens
pour distinguer si vous voulez un
démarchage téléphonique de un sondage ou
une enquête et donc aujourd'hui on ne on
a mis en oeuvre
les dispositions qui étaient dans la loi
la PPL chaise mais on ne peut pas aller
plus loin à notre niveau
on a bien été alerté sur ces sujets j'ai
rencontré les personnes mais je voilà il
faut c'est à mon avis plus du ressort
législatif que du ressort réglementaire
la persistance de zone blanche vous êtes
encore plusieurs à avoir
soulever mon attention sur ce sujet j'en
suis parfaitement consciente et je suis
parfaitement consciente aussi que
lorsque vous avez un seul opérateur sur
une zone et non pas un choix d'opérateur
sans dire un nombre il y a une satisfa
il y a une situation qui est aujourd'hui
pas satisfaisante
on a ça en tête on réfléchi on avait mis
en consultation publique récemment le
futur des réseaux mobiles avec une
question
adressée aux collectivités de savoir et
ce qui a matière à réfléchir à un
nouveau par exemple un New Deal 2 et
comment on peut le faire et donc voilà
nous on est vraiment ouvert à ce que on
puisse encore améliorer la couverture
mobile dans tous les territoires et en
particulier dans dans les territoires
ruraux je vous redis aussi qu'on est
très favorable à la mutualisation des
antennes relais et
que mais en revanche il y a quand même
un principe en France que la liberté
d'entreprendre et donc
tout ce qui peut être cadré doit être
fait par la loi mais mais nous ne
pouvons pas au niveau réglementaire si
ce n'est dire qu'on est favorable et
avoir publié les lignes directrices pour
dire qu'on est favorable à la
mutualisation donc les opérateurs
peuvent pas vous dire ben non la recette
ça serait contre contraire à ce que veut
la recette en matière de concurrence en
l'occurrence non il peut pas vous ils
peuvent pas prétexter cela
il y avait une question aussi on
revenait sur le déploiement de la fibre
sur les zonami
il est légitime en fait la question des
collectivités de savoir si ils peuvent
déployer à la place de l'opérateur qui a
souscrit les engagements auprès du
gouvernement et complètement légitime
sur cette question et moi ça ne me
choquerait pas que ça soit le cas c'est
pas que tu ressors de la recette mais ça
me choquerait pas et pour être franche
je l'ai déjà dit à Orange
donc
voilà je pense que vu la situation par
ailleurs juridique on est un petit peu
bloqué pour avancer
dans les actions qu'on peut faire
vis-à-vis d'orange pour lui faire
respecter ses obligations mais en
revanche je trouve que la question est
légitime pour les collectivités de se
poser la question sur la reprise des
déploiements
il y a un point sur lequel je n'ai pas
répondu tout à l'heure concernant la
collecte du cuivre quand il y a un
raccordement fibre
d'effectuer chez les personnes et en
fait la récupération du cuivre
quand c'est possible techniquement sera
effectué par Orange au moment de la
fermeture du réseau techniquement du
cuivre donc ça viendra plutôt dans un
deuxième temps
il y a eu oui et monsieur le sénateur
vous vous soulevez la question de la
qualité de service que ça soit sur la
fibre ou sur le cuivre c'est un enjeu
pour lequel je suis particulièrement
sensible
parce que c'est pas acceptable
aujourd'hui d'être privé de réseauter
téléphonique ou de réseaux Internet
pendant les durées qui sont celles qu'on
constate
de temps en temps sur le terrain sur la
qualité de service cuivre il y avait eu
une légère amélioration en 2021 le sujet
n'est pas d'aujourd'hui la qualité de
service du réseau cuivre vous aviez
alerté alerté l'ARCEP déjà en 2017 et et
mon prédécesseur avait mis en demeure
orange de respecter ses obligations
la situation c'était un peu améliorée
c'était à nouveau dégradé en 2020 en
2021 la pression a été faite par les
élus par le gouvernement et parlait
alors un plan cuivre a été mis en place
par par Orange et la situation c'est un
peu amélioré
le Premier ministre avait demandé au
préfet de mettre en place des comités de
concertation du cuivre dans chacun des
territoires chaque département
ça a été fait dans les départements où
le cuivre était le plus mauvais état et
je constate aujourd'hui que que ça soit
dans les indicateurs que nous avons ou
que ça soit sur les remontées d'alerte
que j'ai
dans les territoires et par les élus que
la situation se dégrade à nouveau et
donc nous allons naturellement instruire
on a il y a un moment ouvert une
procédure sur ce sujet et nous allons
inscrire donc
cette situation pour
pour utiliser notre notre pouvoir de
sanction
à bon escient et pour faire en sorte que
le maintien telle qualité de sa vie
puisse être là jusqu'à la fermeture de
ce réseau
je crois que vous avez posé une question
par rapport à une
PPL qu'il a déposé
je sais pas si vous avez donné la
réponse monsieur chevrolier
collectionneur est posé une question sur
une proposition qui était en train de
rédiger sur
sur le fait et
pour voir mais il me semble que j'ai pas
répondu
sur l'installation de nouvelles antennes
que ce soit l'opérateur qui qui prennent
en charge les marges d'information au
public et non pas la collectivité locale
il faut qu'on regarde dans le détail
votre proposition de loi moi je
l'information en tout cas est nécessaire
après il faut que ça soit aussi enfin il
faut qu'on regarde la proposition de loi
merci
quand vous parlez madame des
insuffisance et des retards d'orange en
matière d'accès à la fibre ou quand nos
collègues et je les fais moi en question
d'actualité évoque le timbre rouge nous
parlons en fait de la dérégulation du
service public
que vous employez madame a régulé
quelque part parce que c'est quand même
ça alors moi je voudrais revenir au
service public postale de proximité
parce que la suppression du timbre rouge
elle s'est doublée de la mise en place à
compter du mois de mars de
l'expérimentation de tourner et
détournées de facteurs allégés sur 68
sites
au-delà du fait que la dématérialisation
proposée par la lettre
urgente cette fameuse
île lettre rouge ignore la fracture
numérique qui concerne 13 millions de
Français moi j'en ai 17% dans mon
département même si le département de la
Dordogne s'emploie à faire disparaître
la facture numérique en déployant le
très haut débit qui couvrira l'ensemble
du territoire à l'horizon 2025 la
réalité de cette réorganisation
porterait de 6 à seulement deux fois par
semaine la tournée du facteur
bien que la direction de La Poste
démente la fin des tournées quotidiennes
il s'agit bien là d'un choix stratégique
l'objectiver étant l'adaptation de au
marché et le gain de compétitivité face
à des groupes spécialisés dans l'envoi
des colis vous l'avez dit et je le
rappelle la Poste perçoit une
compensation de l'État au minimum 500
millions d'euros par an pour l'exercice
du service public après la réduction de
la présence postale très notoire et
significative dans nos territoires
ruraux cette démarche nous le savons et
les deux natures accentuer la
déshumanisation de nos services publics
lorsque l'on connaît que et vous le
savez que derrière la tournée du facteur
les liens humains qui se tissent avec la
population sont importants et surtout en
direction des plus fragiles alors moi je
voudrais connaître votre avis sur le
sujet parce que l'objectif étant la
recherche d'économie personnelle à mon
avis
merci monsieur le Président merci me
donner la parole j'avais peur de pas
avoir le temps de féliciter Patrick
chaise pour son action à nos côtés
de questions madame la Présidente la
première concerne la 5G est-ce qu'on
pourrait avoir un peu une information
sur l'avenir de la 5G la façon ça va
être déployé la 4G il y a eu le New Deal
ça a été à peu près bien organisé sur
l'ensemble des territoires même si ça
marche pas partout mais la 5G c'est la
multiplication à nouveau des pylônes le
rayon d'action est très faible de 700
mètres où il faut mettre un oppylône
pour avoir un nouveau de la 5G et donc
voir un peu comment vous entendez ou
comment la cependant un peu organisée je
crois le dépôt de cette de cette 5G
pardon la deuxième question concerne les
réseaux d'initiative public certains
élus locaux se sont inquiétés des
difficultés pour réaliser les
raccordements ou dans la gestion du
service les opérateurs commerciaux
d'envergure nationale laissent parfois
leurs clients sans solution pendant de
longues semaines ils mettent en cause le
gestionnaire de réseau ou les
collectivités locales en charge de
l'aménagement numérique du territoire
alors même qu'il ne signale pas aux
gestionnaire de réseau les problèmes
rencontrés cela empêche l'intervention
du gestionnaire de réseau qui n'est pas
autorisé à intervenir sans un ticket
d'incident de l'opérateur cette
situation détériole a confiance de la
population et cette citation est
particulièrement sensible pour les
opérateurs qui n'ont pas encore acquis
l'expérience d'intervenir sur un réseau
dont ils ne sont pas propriétaires
quelle action si possible c'est
peut-elle mettre en œuvre pour vérifier
que les opérateurs commerciaux signalent
dans des délais acceptables et problèmes
rencontrés sur les réseaux dont ils ne
sont pas propriétaires
merci la parole est à Fabien je n'ai
oui merci président merci madame la
Présidente je voudrais saluer votre la
qualité de votre intervention et votre
liberté de ton rendre hommage à votre
rôle d'arbitre dont nous avons bien
compris que certains voulaient vous
arracher le sifflet mais on mesure
combien il vous reste des cartons jaunes
et des cartons rouges à poser à des faux
de carton orange
vous évoquiez les arsépiènes et les
arsépièmes alors je me demandais à
l'heure de la sortie d'Astérix de quelle
tribu il pouvait bien s'agir en tous les
cas une tribu qui semble-t-il doit
résister face aux légions parfois
hostiles des grands opérateurs mais ici
au Sénat c'est vrai que nous avons notre
Panoramix à nous Patrick chaise qui
nous nourrit toujours d'une certaine
potion magique alors au-delà de ces
trait d'humour dans un sujet
effectivement dont il a été rappelé par
l'ensemble de mes collègues combien il
est important pour notre territoire
peut-être trois observations tout
d'abord
sur le déploiement de la fibre comme
ancien vice-président de mon département
chargé du déploiement de la fibre à
partir de 2015
c'est vrai que jusqu'à ce que j'entre au
Sénat j'ai surtout fait des réunions de
crise avec l'opérateur historique pour
trouver des solutions pour qu'il veuille
bien commencer les études préalables au
déploiement donc je mesure le chemin
parcouru et je crois qu'il faut quand
même
à l'occasion de votre audition saluer
la réalisation que représente quand même
le déploiement d'un réseau national de
fibres en quelques années finalement
c'est au final tout de même une certaine
réussite vous saluez le succès collectif
et effectivement l'ensemble des
collectivités qui ont bien voulu prendre
cette compétence mettre de l'argent en
pot je pense qu'on peut saluer leurs
efforts alors comme d'autres de mes
collègues
j'insiste également sur le terrain à
l'emploi d'un certain nombre de
sous-traitants et de personnels qui
travaillent dans des conditions
parfois très compliqué et c'est vrai
qu'avec l'ensemble des maires de mon
département lorsqu'on les voit
travailler on se dit qu'on peut
peut-être se poser des questions sur le
fonctionnement du réseau ensuite donc il
y a sur le terrain beaucoup beaucoup de
d'interrogations sur cela et
d'ailleurs je voudrais vous avez déjà
amorcé un centre de réponses mais vous
demandez quel regard vous vous portez
sur l'écosystème de ces entreprises de
ses sous-traitants de leur capacité à
recruter demain suffisamment d'experts
pour pouvoir finalement faire
fonctionner le service je voudrais
insister à nouveau sur les non
raccordables parce que beaucoup de
questions vous ont été posées là-dessus
et il est vrai que on se dit que
instruit par l'exemple des zones
blanches de la téléphonie mobile nous
imaginons que le régulateur a
certainement dû imaginer
des solutions pour pallier dès à présent
là l'existence finalement de zone
blanche en fibres demain lorsque
effectivement il restera les pourcents
de de non raccordables donc quelle
solution pour nous offrir à nos
concitoyens pour que nous puissions
garantir un égal accès à la fibre sur
l'ensemble du territoire
deuxième remarque sur le réseau cuivre
très rapidement vous avez évoqué la
fermeture de ce réseau sur le terrain ce
que nous vivons c'est pas la
problématique de la fermeture c'est la
problématique de l'abandon de l'abandon
du réseau cuivre par l'opérateur
historique avec des câbles qui restent
au sol pendant des semaines et des
semaines avec des interventions qu'il
est extrêmement difficile à obtenir donc
avant même de se poser la question du
timing de la fermeture comment peut-on
faire face à cette abandon du réseau
cuivre qui a déjà lieu avec le mois puis
dernière question un peu technique
cet hiver avec le risque d'un
rationnement de l'énergie électrique et
des coupures de courant le la
problématique de des conséquences que
cela pourra avoir sur les réseaux de
télécommunications cette problématique a
été abordée donc est-ce que en tant que
régulateur vous vous posez ce genre de
question
quelle résilience quelle sensibilité du
réseau comme à la problématique
électrique demain avec un réseau fibre
qui fonctionnera très largement avec
l'électricité bien sûr l'inquiétude
aussi c'est qu'en cas de coupure et bien
on soit privé de beaucoup plus de
services finalement que qu'auparavant
comment vous voyez cette ce sujet merci
beaucoup merci la parole est à Jacques
Ferny et puis après madame prévu qui
voulait donner un complément et puis
après Bruno Belin et puis Gilbert
Favreau merci président madame la
Présidente oui vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure la recette a élargi son
périmètre à la à la prise en compte des
enjeux environnementaux du numérique et
parmi les leviers déterminants
identifiés il y a le reconditionnement
des produits alors j'ai vu l'étude
récente de l'ADEME fait apparaître par
exemple que pour un mobile reconditionné
en termes d'impact global ça permet une
réduction qui peut aller entre 64 et
87%. c'est pas rien
cette étude est le pointe les conditions
qui permettraient de le plus possible
l'impact environnemental et les
paramètres il y a le nombre de pièces
changer évidemment il y a la durée
d'utilisation totale du produit il y a
la localisation autant de la du
reconditionnement que de
l'approvisionnement pièce de rechange
alors fort de cette étude quels sont à
votre avis les actions les dispositifs
les plus importants qu'il faudrait
déployer pour exploiter pleinement ce
potentiel de réduction de l'empreinte du
numérique alors
de façon complémentaire il y a eu un
riche travail on le sait parlementaire
sur cette question là je salue
d'ailleurs notre collègue pas trichesse
il a été hélas l'opportunité pour le
gouvernement de faire passer la
suppression de l'exonération de la
redevance copie privée pour le secteur
du reconditionné justement
si je ne me trompe pas cette redevance
est appliquée depuis quelques mois
quels effets impactent selon vous
comment aider ce secteur fragile et
émergent à maintenir sa croissance dans
ces conditions
merci Madame privil pour un compliment
oui merci monsieur le Président c'était
pour vous redemander parce que vous
n'avez pas répondu à ma question sur les
abonnements à des journaux qui sont
distribués par la poste et donc sur le
devenir de ces abonnements puisque très
clairement on ne reçoit pas le journal
tous les jours
la parole
merci monsieur le Président alors
contrairement à tous mes collègues je ne
citerai pas l'excellent Patrick chaise
et deux sujets très simples
le premier je comprends pas tout
évidemment mais j'ai l'impression qu'il
y a une tension Orange il y a eu une
audition ici de la directrice générale
d'orange devant la Commission des
Affaires économique j'ai relu un peu le
verbatim l'évoque les sanctions
possibles etc enfin je regarde Gilbert
Favreau parce que quand on a travaillé
ensemble pour le déploiement de la fibre
sur les territoires dont on avait la
responsabilité heureusement que les élus
locaux ont eu souvent orange parce que
je me demande comment on aurait fait 100
en tout cas on n'aurait pas pu faire
donc
je crois qu'il faut y être plus en
soutien cette maison qui nous est utile
et par contre là je demandais au service
du département que j'ai présidé dans le
schéma qu'on a fait durant les cinq
dernières années 47 pylônes on a mis en
moyenne 4 ans
quatre ans je vous ai déjà fait la
salade remarque la dernière fois que
vous étiez venu c'était dans sale
Clémenceau je m'en rappelle bien donc ma
question est simple à quelle heure on
passe à la vitesse TGV pour l'ouverture
des pylônes entre la mise en service
entre leur autorisation et la mise en
service
l'autorité qui a le grand A de la
recette et montrer que vous êtes une
vraie autorité pour que les choses
avancent enfin dans ce pays en terme de
téléphonie mobile
bien comme Bruno Belin a évoqué Gilbert
Faro c'est la parole est à fond oui je
voudrais rapidement revenir madame la
Présidente sur votre propos liminaire
vous évoquez
l'empreinte numérique en indiquant que
en France
elle était estimée à 2% des émissions
carbone et
vous évoquez ensuite rapidement
l'importance des terminaux notamment des
télévisions et autres appareils
de ce type dans la production
de des émissions carbone j'aimerais
savoir si ce 2% que vous évoquez
correspond clairement à l'ensemble des
émissions carbone alors que
vous prenez en compte des données qui
sont produites pour beaucoup d'entre
elles et stockées à l'étranger mais
seulement consommer en France
où se situe l'évaluation est-ce qu'on
prend en compte ce qui est justement
consommer en France mais est-ce qu'on
prend en compte également le stockage et
la production à l'étranger
merci la parole est à Jean-Claude
Anglard et puis madame
finira merci monsieur le président
madame la Présidente
ma question rejoint un peu la
problématique à poser Fabien Genet
concernant
l'arrêt du réseau cuivre alors nous
avions posé la question avec 14
sénateurs du Massif central en 2021 nous
attendons toujours réponse donc orange à
officialiser en février 2022 l'arrêt du
réseau cuivre d'ici 2030 mais le service
public universel est garanti et je crois
que c'est une c'est une démission de la
recette donc comment ça va se passer
comment va se passer va se passer la
prise en charge de l'entretien du réseau
cuivre quelle est ma question en
m'excusant de Madame la présence si vous
avez déjà répondu parce que je suis
arrivé en retard
la parole est à Marie-Laure finira merci
monsieur le Président merci Madame ma
présidente alors c'est vrai que les
collègues ont déjà évoqué des sujets qui
me tiennent aussi à cœur par rapport à
mon territoire mais j'irai droit au but
en Guyane française il y a 3 ans les
opérateurs c'était associés pour réduire
la zone blanche entre coups et sinamaris
soit une soixantaine de kilomètres mais
il reste encore la zone blanche entre
cinnamaris et Saint-Laurent soit près de
200 km quotidiennement des centaines de
guyanais empreinte cette route et ne
peuvent appeler les secours en cas
d'accident il en est de même pour la
route entre Kayes et Regina soit 183 km
moi je pense que vous connaissez mon
territoire la Guyane une seule
infrastructure routière tout le long du
littoral sachez que il y a des communes
de l'Intérieur qui sont enclavés qui
n'ont pas de route qui n'ont pas de
couverture numérique c'est vrai qu'on
parlait tout à l'heure du timbre rouge
on parlait du du on parle de maison de
service public mais c'est clair que son
numérique c'est pas possible voilà alors
madame la Présidente je voudrais vous
poser une question que comptez-vous
faire pour obliger les opérateurs à
respecter leurs engagements merci
beaucoup
vous avez la parole pour cette troisième
série de questions merci merci je vous
remercie de faire ça par Série 3
questions parce que ça me permet aussi
de repérer des questions auxquelles je
suis pas répondu dans le premier slave
et c'est beaucoup plus confortable et
efficace comme ça
j'avais des questions sur le service
postal et je voudrais d'abord parler de
la distribution des quotidiens que
j'avais oublié de la question à laquelle
j'avais oublié de répondre au départ
la Poste à l'obligation de distribuer
quotidiennement les quotidiens voilà
s'il y a des cas particuliers moi je
suis intéressé par les avoir bien
évidemment et dans le nous suivons les
indicateurs de qualité de sa vie de la
Poste concernant l'ensemble de ces
obligations et nous avons naturellement
les mêmes pouvoirs que vis-à-vis du
secteur des télécom sur le suivi des
indicateurs de qualité de service de la
poste
et je rebondis en veillant en ayant
répondu sur l'obligation faite à la
poste de distribuer quotidiennement les
journaux quotidiens s'ils sont
transportés par la poste par la question
concernant les tournées des facteurs
je voudrais préciser l'organisation
industrielle de la Poste savoir comment
elle s'organise c'est du ressort de la
stratégie de la poste c'est pas du
ressort de la recette nous nous avons la
responsabilité de veiller au respect par
la poste de ces obligations
donc
s'il y a un journal à distribuer
quotidiennement par la poste il faut
qu'à cette maison là en tout cas la pose
pas scolidiennement
mais on peut pas intervenir
naturellement dans le choix stratégique
de la Poste d'organisation des tournées
ça serait ça serait pas du ressort de la
régulation c'est
un autre sort je dis ça par rapport à
votre marque concernant la présence
postale la présence postale est garantie
par la poste il y a 17000 points de
présence en France qui sont inscrits en
dur dans dans la loi
donc
on peut pas dire et et on suit à la
recette suit les engagements de la poste
là dessus et je vous confirme qu'il y a
bien 17000 points de présence postale en
France à ce jour
[Musique]
sans doute
sans aucun doute pardon
concernant les questions concernant
l'environnement et le
reconstitutionnement donc on met en
avant au travers de nos travaux les
bonnes pratiques
mais pas nécessairement en revanche la
façon d'organiser les filières ou c'est
pas du ressort de la recette mais on a
mis en avant qu'il fallait travailler
bien sûr sur un meilleur
reconditionnement
déterminaux des mobiles mais pas que des
mobiles des autres terminaux ça peut
être des ordinateurs ça peut être les
téléviseur ça peut être aussi d'assurer
une plus grande réparabilité et je pense
que tous ces thèmes en fait diffusent
dans dans la prise de conscience de la
population de cet enjeu et des enjeux de
l'impact environnemental du numérique
sa ou est un autre une autre raison mais
on voit aujourd'hui que la durée de
des terminaux mobiles est plutôt plus
longue qu'elle n'était aujourd'hui
qu'elle n'était avant on change moins
souvent de
mobiles
concernant l'impact de la taxe copie
privée sur le reconditionnement des
mobiles
j'ai un ami mais je n'ai pas de mesures
sur ce sujet là je crois que la taxe a
pas encore été fixée pour des raisons de
procédure donc elle est pas encore
effectivement en oeuvre et il verra sa
gouvernement verra certainement à
mesurer l'impact de cette axe sur le
reconditionnement mais là aussi ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas du ressort de l'ARCEP
de de le faire
sur les aspects sur la façon dont est
calculé le 2% ce que je vous propose
monsieur le sénateur c'est que vous me
donniez vos coordonnées et puis que je
puisse vous informer sur les aspects
méthodologiques du calcul des 2%
concernant maintenant les sujets de
télécom alors je vais parler de la
Guyane il y a un appel en cours à
candidature sur l'attribution de
fréquences en Guyane actuellement dans
le cadre de cet appel à candidature
larsep préalablement à cet appel à
candidature à travailler avec les
collectivités avec la collectivité de
Guyane pour identifier
les zones qui doivent être couverts et
les obligations qui doivent être mis
pour les opérateurs dans le cadre de cet
appel à candidature donc on a veillé à
faire ça et à ce travail avec les
collectivités pour améliorer la
couverture en Guyane
sur la résilience c'est un sujet qui est
plutôt des des réseaux de
télécommunication c'est un sujet qui est
plutôt du ressort de l'État mais nous
avons décidé cette année de regarder
quand même
sous forme d'un atelier pour pouvoir
monter en compétences sur ce sujet
l'impact de la résilience des
télécommunications notamment au regard
des événements météo qui quelquefois
mettent à mal les réseaux de les réseaux
fixes voir quelquefois les mobiles du
changement climatique aussi et du
réchauffement quel est l'impact de
réchauffement sur les équipements réseau
est-ce que ça perturbe le fonctionnement
des réseaux et donc ça sera aussi
l'occasion de regarder qu'est-ce qui
peut être prévu vis-à-vis de des
opérations de délaissage si on en avait
pour assurer une continuité en fait de
service des télécommunications
concernant les nombreuses questions
concernant la qualité de sa vie que ça
soit sur la fibre ou que ça soit sur le
réseau cuivre
[Musique]
je pense que j'ai déjà beaucoup répondu
ce que pour monsieur le sénateur de
nicolasy ce que j'ai dit quand même qui
est important c'est qu'il y a ne
serait-ce que deux ans
les opérateurs n'avaient pas mis en
place les processeurs de contrôle et les
processus d'échange suffisants pour
pouvoir savoir repérer qui faisait quoi
et quand sur les réseaux donc c'est ces
sujets ont été instruits sous l'égide de
l'harceb et aujourd'hui il y a un plan
d'action de la filière pour mettre en
place ces processus de contrôle et
d'intervention c'est c'est en train de
se décliner et donc on espère qu'on
verra le bénéfice de ces actions
courants 2023
sur le Service Universel et sur maintien
de la qualité de service sur le réseau
cuivre alors le réseau cuve est
propriété d'orange donc c'est de la
responsabilité d'orange d'assurer la
qualité de service sur les réseaux
cuivre
indépendamment je dirais du service
universel sachant qu'aujourd'hui le
service universel téléphonique n'existe
plus depuis décembre 2020
et
l'État annoncé Jean-Noël baron a annoncé
en décembre
2022 l'ouverture de la réflexion sur un
nouveau droit d'accès à 30 mégas pour
tous les Français et donc les services
de l'État travaillent sur la mise en
place en fait d'un nouveau service
anniversaire ou d'un droit d'accès à 30
mégabits pour tous les pour tous les
Français
et un point sur la 5G aussi concernant
le la densification de la 5G et de
savoir comment ça va se déployer sur
tous les territoires donc il y a une
obligation dans les licences des
opérateurs il y a une obligation de
fournir la 5G sur tous les sites à terme
alors le terme étant 2030 mais d'ici là
il y a une obligation qui a été fixée à
l'ensemble des opérateurs d'apporter ce
qu'on a appelé la 4G plus donc 75% des
sites des sites mobiles en France
doivent être connectés avec un débit
minimum de 240 MB d'ici fin de l'année
85% d'ici fin 2024 et puis
progressivement comme ça pour assurer au
moins un débit satisfaisant sur la
majorité des sites mobiles en attente de
la 5G
et puis il y a aussi des objectifs de
couverture de certaines zones
prioritaires en milieu rural notamment
les territoires d'industrie
je crois qu'il y a une dernière question
de la part de Martin de Sidrac oui merci
président merci madame la Présidente
pour toutes pour toutes les réponses que
vous nous avez apportées moi j'en avais
une dernière qui s'inscrit un petit peu
dans la continuité de l'observation qu'a
faite notre collègue Bruno Belin pour
une fois je ne cite pas Patrick chaise
voilà plus sérieusement madame la
Présidente nous avons tous vu
effectivement que aujourd'hui il y a
très clairement un désaccord entre vous
et l'opérateur Orange on a suivi et on
voit que ça prend des proportions qui
peuvent être aujourd'hui considérés
comme inquiétant pour nos territoires
puisque comme l'a dit Bruno Belin c'est
un opérateur qui est très implanté dans
nos différents territoires donc je ne
veux pas vous poser la question sur le
fond de ce désaccord etc vous avez vous
avez floré le sujet à travers un certain
nombre de réponses déjà apportées je
voulais vous poser une question très
simple c'est à dire comment quelle est
la solution de sortie en la qualité de
ce désaccord puisque bien évidemment
vous en tant que
que régulateur vous faites votre job si
je peux m'exprimer ainsi et d'un autre
côté nous avons un opérateur aujourd'hui
historique et implanté dans nos
territoires et qui aussi fait valoir un
certain nombre d'arguments donc sans
rentrer dans le vous voyez dans le débat
de fond
quelle est la quelle est la porte de
sortie aujourd'hui pour que on ne se
retrouve pas puisque j'ai un petit peu
la même je dirais la même inquiétude si
je peux le dire comme ça
pour nos territoires c'est à dire que
demain nos élus lorsqu'ils vont être
confrontés à Orange si j'ai envie de
dire la guerre est déclarée que se
passe-t-il pour nous que se passe-t-il
dans nos territoires concrètement je
vous remercie
et qu'elle est donc la porte de sortie
selon vous
je remercie je remercie pour cette
question
la porteuse sorcier c'est certainement
de le dialogue donc le dialogue est
pardon pu bien sûr avec Orange
l'actualité est un petit peu brûlante
vous l'avez vu et vous nous demandez
aussi le Parlement nous demande à le
gouvernement aussi nous demande de jouer
notre rôle de régulateur et notre rôle
c'est de contrôler
les obligations souscrites par les
opérateurs et de les faire respecter
donc il y a des tensions avec les
opérateurs je dirais c'est normal ça
c'est la vie du régulateur
et donc bien évidemment je suis
extrêmement attentive à ce que cette
situation
ne soit pas au détriment des des
communes mais ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que si vous vous voyez votre
voisin sénateur de la Vendée si j'ai
compris
dire c'est on arrive on n'arrive pas
enfin les déploiements sont
ralentis en fait et on n'a pas de
d'autres personnes m'ont dit on pas
d'échéancier on n'a pas de calendrier on
a pas de voilà on n'a pas de visibilité
sur les déploiements de la fibre en zone
amie donc nous avons joué notre rôle de
régulateur et il faut pas non plus que
Orange s'étonne à ce que
nous soyons un régulateur exigeant c'est
ce que vous nous demandez aussi
mais je vous promets une chose le
dialogue est pas rompu avec Orange je
les rencontre très régulièrement et on
échange aussi de de situation concernant
le futur de discussion et bien
évidemment de
de la volonté qu'elle le régulateur à ce
que tant sur la qualité en termes
d'objectif et d'obligation que sur les
dépoulements ils respectent et
respectent leurs obligations
bien je vous
remercie je vous remercie mes collègues
pour toutes les questions c'est un sujet
comme vous avez pu constater
qui nous préoccupe qui nous préoccupe
nos territoires qui préoccupent nos
concitoyens donc c'est un sujet qui
préoccupe bien sûr les élus du Sénat qui
sont des élus
issus du territoire et effectivement il
faut qu'on trouve les moyens pour et
bien régulariser et mettre en place
toute cette politique qui est
indispensable aujourd'hui pour nos
concitoyens je vous remercie et puis je
vous demande de rester quelques minutes
qu'il y a un ordre du jour numéro 2 il y
en a pour